[موسيقى]
لما يكون في تراند معين بالسوشال ميديا
العالم بتزيد دوري عنده الفضول وكانه في
شيء جديد بحياه وبجاربه الابلكيشنز
الجديده خاصه انه بتعلي دغري نسبه
الدوبامين اللي هو يعني الهاتف
صور اصغر واحلى وعم بيشيله كل اذا في شيء
يدف ومعين او عم بجنبله الصور وبالتالي
الشخص بينبسط بحاله يعني بفكر انه هو هذا
الصوره احلى بشوف حاله اصغر بطريقه مختلفه
وعنده هل شعور بالستفه
اللي هو كمان بياثر عليه
هو بخليه يتعلق بالابلكيشن اكثر صار الشخص
عندكم
يفتش على طريقه حتى يكون اصغر حتى يكون
حليلي معقوله يزيد من التراب الجسم اللي
هو انه واحد غير راضي عن شكله
كثره الوقت على السوشيال ميديا كثره
المقارنه همم كثره الشعور بانه واحد في
اموره معي انا ما عندي اياها او غير مبسوط
بشكل
عن شكله كثير بتاثر على الثقه بالنفس
الابلكيشن صاروه على الميديا عم بيخلوا
الشخص يتعلق اكثر بوهم وبالتالي عم بنقول
لدماغ دايما انه اللي عنا مش مبسوطين فيه
وهذا الشيء كثير بيعمل غاب بين الواقع
والعالم الافتراضي والعالم الخيالي يؤدي
الى قدمين زيد باذن الله نرجسيه زايده
بتادله الترابيت مثل الديسموفيا والقلق
والاكتئاب